>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
WE ALMOST NEVER USE THE TERM
DEEP STATE ON THIS SHOW.
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT IT THAT
SOUNDS PARANOID, EVEN A LITTLE
NUTTY.
AS OF JUST A FEW YEARS AGO YOU
MOSTLY HEARD THE PHRASE FROM
RELICS ON THE FAR LEFT, THE KIND
OF PEOPLE WHO LECTURE YOU ABOUT
THE UNITED FRUIT COMPANY.
THE TERM THEN AND NOW SUGGESTS
THAT OUR DEMOCRACY IS FAKE.
ELECTIONS AND DOMESTIC POLITICS
ARE JUST A SIDESHOW NO MATTER
WHO YOU VOTE FOR IN THE END, THE
SAME PEOPLE STILL
RUN EVERYTHING PEER THAT IS A
PRETTY DARK UNDERSTANDING OF THE
AMERICAN SYSTEM.
IF YOU ARE A NORMAL PERSON WHO
GREW UP HERE IT IS THE LAST
THING YOU WANT TO BELIEVE ABOUT
YOUR OWN COUNTRY.
IT SEEMS CRAZY.
THEN YOU READ STORIES LIKE THIS
ONE.
ACCORDING TO REPORTING THIS
SUMMER IN THE DAYS AFTER LAST
NOVEMBER'S ELECTION, THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS OF
SCRATCH HELD A MEETING WITH
SENIOR MILITARY OFFICIALS AT THE
PENTAGON.
GENERAL MILLIE WANTED TO INFORM
THEM OF WHAT HE DESCRIBED AS A
SERIOUS THREAT TO NATIONAL
SECURITY.
A THREAT SO GRAVE IT IMPALED
"THE STABILITY OF THE REPUBLIC.
THAT THREAT, MILLIE SAID, WAS
THE SITTING PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
DONALD TRUMP QUESTION TO THE
ELECTION.
FOR THIS, -- FORCE AGAINST THE
U.S. PRESIDENT.
WHERE THE GUYS WITH GUNS, MILLIE
SAID.
APPARENTLY HE HAD BEEN PREPARING
FOR THIS MOMENT.
HE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
HEAD OF THE CSA AND THE NSA.
HE HAD ALSO SPOKEN DIRECTLY TO
CHUCK SCHUMER AND NANCY PELOSI,
DONALD TRUMP'S CHIEF POLITICAL
RIVALS.
NOW ACCORDING TO A NEW BOOK BY
BOB WOODWARD AND BOB COSTA,
APPARENTLY HE WENT EVEN FURTHER
THAN THAT.
LAST YEAR, MILLIE CALLED HIS
COUNTERPART IN CHINA, GENERAL.
HE DID NOT TELL HIS BOSS, THE
PRESIDENT COME ABOUT THIS CALL
EITHER BEFORE HE MADE AT OR
AFTER.
HERE WAS MILLIE'S MESSAGE FOR
THE CHINESE MILITARY.
"GENERAL LEE, I WANT TO ASSURE
YOU THE AMERICAN GOVERNMENT IS
STABLE AND EVERYTHING IS GOING
TO BE OKAY.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO ATTACK OR
CONDUCT ANY KINETIC OPERATIONS
AGAINST YOU.
AND THEN REPORTEDLY MILLIE SAID
THIS, GENERALLY, YOU AND I HAVE
KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR FIVE YEARS.
IF WE ARE GOING TO ATTACK, I'M
GOING TO CALL YOU AHEAD OF TIME,
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE A
SURPRISE.
LET THAT SINK IN, IF WE ARE
GOING TO ATTACK, I'M GOING TO
CALL YOU AHEAD OF TIME.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE A SURPRISE.
SO ACCORDING TO THIS ACCOUNT,
OUR COUNTRY POSITIVIST TOP
DEFENSE OFFICIALS SECRETLY
COLLUDED WITH THE CHIEF MILITARY
RIVAL TO UNDERCUT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE THAT?
DEEP STATE IS NOT STRONG ENOUGH.
THAT'S TREASON.
IT IS A CRIME.
IT APPARENTLY MARK MILLIE IS NOT
THE ONLY PERSON WHO WAS
IMPLICATED IN THIS CRIME.
OTHERS KNEW WHAT WAS HAPPENING
AS I DID.
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES ALMOST
CERTAINLY HEARD MIKE MILLIE'S
CALL.
IF THEY CAN READ EMAILS FROM A
CABLE NEWS SHOW ON FOX, OVER THE
THE CHANCES THAT THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF WAS
SPEAKING TO A SENIOR CHINESE
GENERAL AND WHAT THEY WERE
SAYING.
CHANCES ARE ABOUT 100%.
YET, THE NSA DID NOTHING ABOUT
IT.
THE CIA WAS MEANWHILE FULLY ON
BOARD WITH THIS.
WE ARE ON OUR WAY TO A
RIGHT-WING COUP, SHE TOLD MILLIE
THAT.
IN FACT, THERE WAS A COUP IN
PROCESS BUT IT DIDN'T COME FROM
THE RIGHT.
IT WASN'T BREWING IN ALABAMA.
INSTEAD A CONSTELLATION OF
EMPLOYEES LOYAL ABOVE ALL TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND PERMANENT
CLASS IN WASHINGTON IGNORED THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION AND
THEN THEY INVALIDATED THE VOTES
OF TENS OF MILLIONS OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
HOW DID THEY DO THAT?
BECAUSE THEY INVALIDATED
DEMOCRACY.
DEMOCRACY DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING
IF THE PEOPLE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE NO POWER, AND MARK MILLIE
DID HIS BEST TO MAKE CERTAIN THE
ELECTED PRESIDENT HAD NO POWER.
IN EARLY JANUARY, WOODWARD AND
BOB COSTA REPORTED, MILLIE
CALLED ANOTHER MEETING AT THE
NATIONAL MILITARY COMMAND
CENTER.
HE INFORMED THIS GROUP THAT THEY
REPORTED TO HIM, NOT THE ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND THAT IS NOT A SMALL CLAIM.
THE NATIONAL MILITARY COMMAND
CENTER CONTROLS AMONG OTHER
THINGS THE NUCLEAR WEAPONS
INSIDE OUR MISSILE SILOS AS WELL
AS THE NUCLEAR WEAPONS ON BOARD
SUBMARINES.
MARK MILLIE WAS SEEKING PERSONAL
CONTROL OF THE AMERICAN NUCLEAR
ARSENAL.
HE RAN AROUND AND DEMANDED
OFFICERS SUBMIT TO HIS
AUTHORITY, NOT THE PRESIDENT.
ACCORDING TO WOODWARD AND COSTA
COME ALL PRESENT IN THE ROOM
AGREED TO THIS.
MARK MILLIE WAS IN CHARGE.
IF THIS IS TRUE, IT IS ONE OF
THE SCARIEST THINGS THAT HAS
EVER HAPPENED IN THIS COUNTRY.
OFTEN PEOPLE SAY THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT AUTHORITARIANISM COMING TO
AMERICA.
WELL, IT'S HERE.
IT'S WHAT IT IS, AUTHORITARIAN
GOVERNMENT BY UNELECTED,
UNACCOUNTABLE LEADERS WILLING TO
USE VIOLENCE TO PRESERVE THEIR
POWER.
THAT IS WHAT THIS BOOK
DESCRIBES.
IT IS SHOCKING.
NOT SURPRISINGLY OUR NEWS MEDIA
SPENT TODAY CELEBRATING IT.
IT TURNS OUT THE SELF-DESCRIBED
DEFENDERS OF DEMOCRACY DON'T
REALLY BELIEVE IN THE SYSTEM
THEY CLAIM TO REVERE.
THE IDEA OF GIVING VOTERS POWER
OVER THEIR OWN GOVERNMENT
REPULSES PEOPLE LIKE THIS.
SO THEY ARE RELIEVED TO DISCOVER
THAT IN FACT OUR DEMOCRACY IS
FAKE.
HERE'S A SELECTION FROM SOME OF
THE PROGRAMMING.
>> I WOULD CALL GENERAL MILLIE A
HERO.
HE BEHAVED IN A HERALDIC MANNER.
>> WHAT HE DID WAS ENSURE THE
GUARDRAILS WERE IN PLACE, SO I
GIVE HIM HIGH MARKS FOR THIS
BASED ON WHAT IS DESCRIBED IN
THE BOOK.
>> I THINK MILLIE FELT ILL USED
IN LAFAYETTE SQUARE WHEN HE WAS
USED AS A PROP, SO ONE CAN
UNDERSTAND MILLIE'S ANXIETIES.
>> WE WERE IN A PERIOD OF
EXTRAORDINARY DANGER.
I THINK GENERAL MILLIE IS GOING
TO BE TREATED VERY FAVORABLY BY
HISTORY.
>> Tucker: THE FIRST GUY USE
ON THIS CLIP IS A MORON,
OBVIOUSLY, THERE IS NO SURPRISE
THERE.
THE SECOND GUY WAS A RETIRED
MILITARY OFFICIAL.
BUT THE LAST TWO?
GEORGE WELL?
BARRY McCAFFREY?
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WHATEVER
YOU THINK OF THEM OR WHO THEY
VOTE FOR, YOU WOULD HAVE
IMAGINED MIGHT DEFEND AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY WHEN IT CAME RIGHT
DOWN TO IT, BUT NO, THEY DIDN'T.
THEY CHEERED ITS ENDING.
THEY ARE HAPPY TO SEE MARK
MILLIE SECRETLY CONSPIRING WITH
THE CHINESE MILITARY TO END
CIVILIAN CONTROL OF THE
PENTAGON.
IT TURNS OUT THAT IS THE
GOVERNMENT THEY WANT AND YOU
SHOULD NOT FORGET THAT.
NOW THAT WE KNOW ALL THIS, WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT?
IN SOME WAYS HE IS THE CENTER OF
THE STORY.
A RETIRED ARMY COLONEL WHO LAST
YEAR ADVISED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ON FOREIGN
POLICY.
HE COAUTHORED A MEMO ASKING U.S.
TROOPS TO LEAVE AFGHANISTAN
FINALLY AFTER 20 YEA